hey chuck
hey hey what's happening neil i'm back
in your face
that's right which means that we're
gonna we're gonna find out about
something
um hopefully that is delightfully
obscure obscure but yes
but the whole part is it will be obscure
the hope is that it's
nonetheless interesting yeah well that's
yeah so far
so far it's going good all right so i
want to talk about earth's magnetic
field
all right already you got me if i yeah
this is good stuff already
okay so um it's
we all know it has a magnetic field and
you learn that as a child when you have
a compass right particularly if you were
like you know in one of the scouts
programs you have a compass and
the needle points north and so that's
north
okay so um so the north side of the
needle points north and that's how you
know it's north
so let me start out by saying
we all know that in magnetic fields
opposites attract right you knew this
yes well you you take the north and the
north you put them together and they
it's very cool because they they repel
yeah and you and then you have magnet
races
push them across the table yes you push
them across the table and that's how you
have a magnet okay so if you flip it
around then the north sticks to the side
okay right so what that means is
if the needle on your compass is
magnetized
north then it's actually pointing
to the earth's south magnetic pole right
that makes sense
because that means what you're calling
the north pole is actually the south
pole
right i just want to start there wow
okay okay thanks for ruining everything
and now i don't know what to believe
okay
period right earth's south magnetic pole
is in the north
because all north magnetic poles point
to it
right okay interesting i just didn't
know if you knew that
uh you know what don't shoot the
messenger i know it now
and i i gotta tell you i wish i didn't
okay so now that that's actually very
cool
but wait there's more uh so earth's
magnetic field
um is not aligned with
earth's rotation axis okay so santa
claus is up there on the north pole
all right and your compass
doesn't actually point to him
okay well it does point to him if you're
exactly on the longitude
where the north magnetic pole is found
if you are anywhere else
you are not pointing to the top of
earth's rotation axis you are pointing
to some place
in northwest canada
because our magnetic pole is tipped
relative to our what we call the
geographic pole
okay so the geographic poles so the
earth sits if you ran the pole
an actual pole through it if you did
it's on this tilted axis
it's tilted that's correct it's tilting
it's tilted by a lot so
it's so a compass sort of points north
sort of
and by the way i i in the scout manuals
this is the device we use to find our
way when we're lost
well
it's like getting directions in the hood
you know
now see what you want to do here man
what you want to do you want to go
straight down
right go straight
right now now that's my cousin
that's my cousin boo right when you get
to cousin boo's house
you won't make a left
that's exactly what it says on the
compass right so
so you uh so what they
the the manuals for using a compass know
about this and it's
it's called an offset so depending on
where you are
on earth's surface when you whip
whip out the the compass you would put
an angle offset to find out what true
north is
but that changes depending on where you
are on earth's surface so it's what i
always had an issue with
is if you knew where you were on earth
service you wouldn't need the company
in the first place absolutely that's
like people say i lost my keys
well where'd you leave them last
what what what
well what was the last place you left
i left them on the counter except like
that is a stupid question right that is
crazy right you know another stupid one
is uh someone gets injured skiing and
they got to be like hauled off to the
hospital
and someone asked him did that did that
happen on your last run
exactly yes of course it did now you
know uh
the thing is i love excruciating pain
and skiing
the pain enhances the skiing experience
so when when my tibula is sticking out
of my leg
that's when i want to get back on the
chairlift
[Laughter]
all right so anyway so so that's what
that's where that is all right
so in the era of gps which knows exactly
where the poles are and what the grid
system is like compasses are
basically completely obsolete plus if
you know any astronomy
you'll know which way north is and which
way the sun is pointing i mean
so so the compass i think is overrated
in this regard
um compared with other ways you can also
find out where
where you are but anyway so that's
earth's magnetic field it's relatively
weak
okay it's weak so if you take a bar
magnet i don't know if anyone still has
them you can do this tie a string
in the middle where it's balanced and
just sort of suspend it there it will
slowly line up with earth's magnetic
field
okay provided the string is is is twisty
enough
so that it can aim where it wants it'll
slowly line up and
the north is going to point north to
earth south magnetic field right
it turns out as weak ass as this field
is
it's not always at the same strength nor
is it always oriented the same way
the magnetic pole of the earth flips
and it has flipped many times wow i
don't know if
anybody knew that that's i don't know
okay this is good
stuff and now i'm really intrigued
at 100 of the times
people of the occasions where people say
i hear the world is going to end and
earth's axis is going to flip
because they heard something about
earth's axis flipping right and they
think somehow santa claus is going to be
south instead of north
when what they read about earth's axis
flipping has been entirely
related to the magnetic field flipping
gotcha
and on earth so the earth is not
actually
tumbling over so that top is bottom and
bottom is top
that has never happened that's never
happened correct what's happening is
the actual magnetic field which is the
thing
surrounding the earth that orientation
changes right and it's not just the part
of it we
measure and see is outside of the earth
right but it's generated from d
from the inside of the but i haven't
gotten there yet but i'm just saying
that this can reduce in strength
come back in a reversed polarity reduce
the strength and come back again and
that flips
and this this goes on every million
years so now i got to know this
in that process is it a
is it an equal diminishing
so that it actually goes down to not
being there at all
and then oh we think so yes so what you
have you have volcanic deposits that had
uh metallic ingredients in it and when
the iron when the the the lava
freezes basically hits room temperature
and freezes
um it's uh it locks in
the magnetic orientation of where that
lava was at that time
and so people who study this can track
the orientation of these magnetic um
rocks as as they get yeah brilliant it's
complete
that is insane yes yes oh my god that's
crazy yes yes okay so
i love it so people wondered
by the way we are shielded from harmful
particles from the sun
by this magnetic field it gets channeled
towards the
magnetic poles and it it
collides with the atmosphere and renders
it aglow and it creates the northern and
southern lights
the aurora borealis and the aurora
australis
okay earth's force field that is or
facts
that is earth's magnetic force field
directing deflecting particles
and that's why they don't all go to
santa claus they go to that the best
shows are in this ring it's called a
ring
it's a highly luminous ring where you
have the best
action of this uh excited air molecules
and it's over canada okay and it's not
that's why we get better aurora borealis
than they do over in russia
because we have the pole over on our
side our
north american side finally something
good about canada
and their health insurance okay canada
you know we love you you know we love
so um so it shield us from that so now
here's here's what's going on inside the
core
you get a magnetic field when you have a
fluid
in this case it would be sort of molten
uh
magnetic materials iron and nickel in
our core all right
and if it's molten it means you can move
you convect
there's movement within this material we
know from
basic electromagnetism 101
if you move a charge okay
you create a current if you create a
current you create a magnetic field
right it's called a dynamo theory of
magnetic
uh fields and this is where we do it in
class you take
the copper wire the copper wire you pass
it through exactly
and you see the meter checked and the
electricity and the magnetism go
together that's why it became one word
exactly right early 1800s i got
electricity and i got magnetism then you
find out one is a manifestation of the
other
we glued the words together and we made
the word electromagnetism
sweet so um because of this when you
have a molten core
of conductive materials in our case it's
metal
you can generate what's called a dynamo
and sustain magnetic fields for millions
of years
wow okay or magnetic field phenomenon so
and as the magnetic field lines get
twisted what happens is they can break
and reconnect and often when they
reconnect
they have the opposite polarity than
they had before and that's what's been
going on on earth
that's so cool forever that's so cool
and by the way the sun's magnetic field
goes through this
the sunspot cycle goes through an
11-year uh
from peak to low and sunspots always
come in pairs
there's a positive and a negative
because they're magnetic i don't know if
you knew they're magnetic they're
magnetic
i did not know that okay so now watch so
watch every 11 years
the sun's magnetic field flips and when
the sunspots show up again they're now
oppositely configured so earth is not
the only thing whose
magnetic field flips it happens to the
sun every 11 years
so this is not a new phenomenon the
understanding of it is relatively modern
you know late
20th century mid to late 20th century
but there it is that's our magnetic
field there's worries
that when we um when the field went to
zero and switched
maybe all the bad particles would come
and kill all life on earth and maybe the
the migration that's when a portal to
another dimension opens
and we are taken over by
that'd be a good story right right the
magnetic field drops to zero what
happens now yeah so so what you do is
you can look at what effect that would
have there also
many animals that it is asserted that
they use the magnetic field
uh particles in their brain to know
which way north and south is there's
navigation to migrate
uh i've not been as convinced as others
have been of that explanation but let's
even give it to them
fine you would wonder will they not know
how to
how to how to fly how to swim how to
migrate from one place to another
to get out of the cold climates in the
in the winter and return in the summer
you look at the fossil record over those
periods and there's no
meaningful extinction episodes happening
over any of these right so whatever our
worries are
earth seems life on earth seems to
survive them just fine
right and everybody knows that birds
don't really use the
uh magnetic field they use uh google
bird maps
google bird maps is you know pretty dope
man plus they can track you and that's
how they know how to [ __ ] on your head
google targeting
that's funny so there you so there you
have it and my my only issue with
whether animals use magnetic fields is
they don't if the animal knows where the
sun rises and sets and
there are other ways to know like i said
if you didn't have a compass you still
can figure it out and so animals are
always smarter than i think we give them
absolutely and the truth of the matter
is um even we
as explorers and being out in the sea
we didn't use magnetic fields we use the
stars we use the stars that's correct
right on a cloudy night it's a little
harder you could
uh crash into the rocks on a cloudy
night but on a clear night you couldn't
right exactly so yeah all right cool man
yeah so there you have it this is
magnetic field
that's fun stuff i love it and by the
way magnetism in general you didn't ask
this but i'm putting it out there
is to understand it we've known about
magnets ever since lodestone
was discovered this rock that contained
the iron that was magnetized before we
isolated the iron from it's called
lodestone
it's still called lodestone um there's
no understanding of magnetic fields
without quantum physics
okay well then we don't understand
magnetism
so sorry guys speak your own damn self
don't understand right
no you got to get down in there and the
electrons
in in orbit in their their orbital
clouds around their
the nuclei there's a point where they
align with adjacent atoms
and once that's aligned and coherent you
have a stable magnetic field
and if you could create you could create
a magnet we used to do this you take a
pin
right a little steel pin and you take a
magnet and it doesn't even have to be a
strong magnet and you just stroke it you
keep stroking right so there you go and
you're
aligning all of those magnetic domains
to create a coherent magnet
now there are other magnets where they
only where they'll only stay magnetized
in the presence of an electric field
and and you remove the electrical then
they demagnetize immediately this is how
you get electromagnets
that's how the trains run uh maybe i
don't know enough about trains but i do
know that thing that picks up cars
in the trash yard not nice it grabs them
by their
thing i'm not talking about the clamps
i'm talking about that no the big
the big disc flat thing the distance
yeah that comes down and it just shows
up
so flip the switch magnet on boom there
it is
and put it bring it to the side magnet
off and you can drop it so that's an
electromagnet
highly uh functional and exploitive of
quantum physics
nice there you go chuck we ran out of
time
wow well that was a good one man i uh
you know
i think this uh this talk will stick
with me for a while
yeah yeah and santa claus that was a bad
magnet joke
i'm sorry okay oh oh sorry i missed it
sorry yeah i'm sorry man
i shouldn't have done that i'm i'm
really embarrassed that i actually did
that i'm sorry
i'm embarrassed i didn't catch it
don't you say uh this this this
explainer will stick to me for a long
time
i would have gotten it right oh by the
way just one other thing if you're
between the north pole
geographic pole and the north uh
geomagnetic pole
if you're between those two your compass
will always point due south
oh wow right because the this damn thing
is broken
yep yep that's that's all i'm saying
awesome there you go chuck all right we
got to call it quits there this has been
another
star talk explainer venue chuck always
good to have you
always a pleasure neil degrasse tyson
here keep looking
you